family if the dad doesn't cheat
um because my dad was in that category
and like i'm very proud of the fact that
my dad doesn't drink doesn't smoke
doesn't cheat like he's just a really
good dude and it gives me someone to
look up to but
i i don't know i it's like if a dude's
worked for 20 years to do this and the
girl agrees to it like who who might
tell you what to do i think they're okay
i think that makes sense right i think
what you just said makes sense yeah the
person in the relationship you're with
um says okay yeah and fair enough but or
if you're dating an nba player and you
get cheated on i don't feel bad for you
uh
jade like that girl jason derulo's chick
who's on instagram saying oh no i got
sorry
oh no i got cheated on boo you're dating
jason derulo what did you think was
gonna happen he was a hoe before he met
you
he meant to you he's still uh it's like
it's like when you when you wife a hoe
it's like she was a hoe before you bet
you yeah like it's the same sorry okay
it's just it's just like because what
bothers me is girls go in acting all
innocent oh i had no idea
but it's like
our intuition is so strong we know when
a dude has options we know when a dude
has [ __ ] so if you should know if you
go after a select type of guy the odds
the chance that he does that is higher
and what are you going to do if he does
if you want to go after that guy that's
something you have to think about yeah
my issue with that with the concept
right because i think they can if they
want to yeah if that's what you want if
that's what you yeah fair enough but
when
kevin samuels first presented the idea
he he very much said they can doesn't
necessarily mean they will right yes
however
um god rest his soul since he's passing
i've seen a lot more red pill people
saying essentially they will and they
should essentially yeah right
monogamy is stupid exactly exactly and
the issue i have with that is because
that message is completely contradictory
to what they say when they they talk
about the fact that those are value men
the only reason why the american human
is for the children and yeah because
they might as well have multiple wives
like i mean modern women are side chicks
anyways
but they might as well like get a hug
like but
like they're doing it like but the
problem with that is the fact that
do you if you saw your dad cheering on
your wife would you respect him on it on
his wife would you respect my dad no i'd
be so sad so
like some girls grow up in that and
they're like good with it like it's
weird i have friends who's like
dad like that was kind of just
yeah yeah like they don't so they're
just like kind of like that's isn't that
how it is in nigeria where they're just
like that's how men are it depends so a
little bit even i think even my granddad
had um one of my granddads had multiple
words but then this is the problem none
of his kids liked him so this is what
i'm talking about so you know i mean i
wouldn't recommend it i'm just like
oh okay do do what you want there's
risks that come with everything yeah so
you pick your poison
yeah but but this is the thing i don't
think they consider yeah and they don't
mention this to the guys when they're
saying all this stuff is like
do you really think your son will
respect you when he sees you cheating on
his mother
especially when fathers and sons always
send to cash anyway do you think that
son will respect you when it comes to
when it comes to that no he won't yeah
and so when you're telling men or
suggesting to men that they should be
doing that i don't know like throughout
all of human history i don't think all
sons hated their dad i'm not saying also
i'm saying like throughout all of
history human history the most powerful
men had concubines yeah so i'm like i
can't imagine all of them do you think
the boss at sunset ended up liking that
no i'm saying i can't imagine that all
the suns hated their dad of course
because it's just it's just how society
is of course but i think society's also
very much moved from the way it wasn't
then
now exactly then if you don't do
monogamy then you get all these unhappy
men because they're you know what i'm
saying like i guess
i'm gonna butcher this but i guess
societies collapse if you have too much
hypergamy and non-monogamy because
they're like the growing number of men
that are sexless just become really
angry
and then start to like do bad things i
guess because like life is bad i don't
know yeah
i mean
i can
we're seeing it now yeah
and and mate guarding because i guess
it's bags mate gordon yeah like um
i i
like a lot of fights and stuff because
make guardians like when you guard your
mate from other
yeah okay yeah yeah actual mates
i guess there's like fights and stuff
that happen
i don't know i i forgot rolo talked
about it once like why monogamy is
better
on his stream and it was like because
without monogamy like the there's like a
bigger number of angry men and then
people fight over
like because they're all sleeping with
each other yeah i mean yeah i mean we
see all the time in just certain areas
where a guy would stab up another guy
because
my goals yeah yeah you see that a lot
yeah i do think that is an issue people
are having and i'm not trying to say to
people or go
monogamous or whatever live your life
the way you want to live however be
aware of the consequences and i think
those consequences need to be spoken
about more within the red bull content
when they're telling men how to live
their lives or when they're telling men
to to be a certain way because they will
end up being
you you're saying a lot of men are
unhappy in marriages which is true but
then a lot of men are also unhappy when
they're dying alone because they yeah
they stepped around they played the
field
but what happens when you're 50 16
you're by yourself
it's probably sad yeah it's sad exactly
and i i think
pushing the narrative that
oh yeah once you i think again this is
something that sneaker says which
i don't i don't want to hate anyone or
anything i don't want to seem like i'm
hating on him but this is something he
says i think he hasn't thought through
the stuff he's saying you know he's
always talking about how he
to an extent he gets fulfillment from um
well the stuff he says implies he gets
fulfillment from having sex with a lot
of girls and just chasing money after
the certain point i think there's a lot
of guys there there are a lot of guys
there's a lot of guys
there there are a lot of guys that say
things like that but it's like
once you get bosses
if you get fulfillment
one in the chat one in the chat
but then
it's once you get past a certain point
and every man who's older than him has
said this to him yeah except from fresh
myron and fresh yeah but every man has
spoken to him had debate with him i said
that and yeah he's so confident in his
stance and he thinks it won't change yet
yeah
and he's with the thing that's crazy the
guy i mean hugh hefner never got sick of
the hose i'm not saying do you think he
was happy when he was dead right he
looked pretty happy i'm not gonna on the
camera yeah but do you really think when
he was dying by himself no no companion
that was like he had a lot of good
looking compare like
but is that just
i wouldn't recommend it but do you think
of your guy that's what you'd want no
i'm saying but some guys do some guys
i think he was chilling he was an
exceptional man
yeah but i'm saying like some guys i
think nba players and that's the thing
like a lot of guys don't really have
consequences for it to be honest because
they can like pay they can pay to play
like it's like you think politicians
don't cheat on their wives
yeah they just they the wives kind of
know what it is they get their escorts
and
you know they're chilling i don't
i just feel like as a 25 year old who's
not in that world how can i tell you how
to live your life like you guys work to
earn it so you don't do what you want
but this this is where
this is where i'm coming from because
i'm not saying you should you should be
telling them how to live their lives but
if you're someone who just says the
facts right that's a fact or that's
something that should probably be put
out there a bit more yeah and that's the
thing that's where i'm coming at this
from whereas i'm not actually trying to
tell people what to do i'm just trying
to show different yeah well another
another
thing i would say another thing though
is that like women love guys that cheat
so
no it's like okay if y'all if you all
hated guys that cheat then why do you
date them
i don't disagree and i've said this on
youtube before like
not a lot of them
i've said this on your show about that
girls love being chicken if a man cheats
on you and you go back to him it's on
you
it sounds like
yeah okay but
i will say
you know
when these people talk about
a man being able to marry multiple women
or be with multiple rings yeah and
talking about
women don't mind
that sort of that sort of thing
i think they mind